i heard i was going to be interviewing
you i i was thinking back about my
experiences
as a child listening to him oh my god
all of it just comes rushing back i'm
like free your mind it's all that i'm
just
i'm ecstatic to see you and you i just
have to tell you guys with the strong
women in my life and your powerful
voices the way you used it
it means so much to me so it's so
wonderful to see you at a time like this
um thank you you continue to use your
voice this new song
i actually sat and i listened to a few
times an angry black woman
closed my eyes and you could feel the
pain you could feel the frustration
you can feel what mothers wives
sisters are going through at a time like
this but you wrote this four years ago
does it have actually take that back
what was that feeling for you when you
initially wrote this song
um well i was working on some music
and um as an artist i always
feel that um you know having the
opportunity to
stand on a platform such as this um
it's important to me that every time i
pick up the microphone i have something
of substance to say
and uh art reflects life right
and um when i was in the studio and
thinking about
what i wanted to record um
at the time that that was happening
which was four years ago
uh i think the first incident uh was um
a police brutality uh was eric garner
and it was just it was so
devastating and and traumatic
um i just wanted to give a voice to
uh what i and so many of my friends and
and family um were feeling and all i
could think about was
how the parents of
all of these black men and women because
now we know that black women are not
excluded from this
um have how they they must feel
and i know i could never convey exactly
how they're feeling but
i know how i felt and i have friends who
have
uh who are raising young black men
yeah and we're having these
conversations constantly
and to see these things happen and and
to
um not get justice for it it's just
it's insane it's insane and it's
heartbreaking
and and i just it was a very cathartic
um moment for me um and release
for me and i just wanted to give a voice
to it
and you talk about talking with sons and
explaining
how they're going to be perceived in the
world growing up
those are tough conversations do you
feel it's a different
conversation now with this generation
i don't think the conversation is uh is
different
i think that
the difference is that it is this
generation
who are having these conversations with
their parents
and they're not understanding it and um
i think they are rising up to speak
against it because
as we're all home uh during this
pandemic
yeah uh everyone
could not um turn away from
what they saw on television uh when that
happened to george floyd
and you know i say if you are i don't
care
what your skin tone is if you are a
human
being and you have a heart that affected
you
um and i don't think it just
happened and affected just black people
there are many many other ethnicities
that it affected and they are
all speaking out about it now i think
that's the difference
you know when you think about that um
social media
media and it there's a line in your song
where you say i don't want to watch
tv and see another see another casualty
and it reminds me of will smith and what
he said you know racism hasn't
uh what's the actual quote he says
racism is not getting worse
it's just getting filmed and when you
think of that these are all trigger
points
when you're on social media and watching
the news
how do you take care of yourself
mentally to make sure
you're okay i
um i i meditate and i pray a lot and i
also write in my gratitude journal um
that's what it takes for me um to rise
above
uh the reality that i'm
in and that the way things appear to be
and it gives me the strength to
be able to see it from another
perspective in order to try and deal
with it
um that's
that's how that's the best way i know
yeah
to handle it it's it's difficult as i
said
you know i'm i talk to many friends and
um who have children and um
and we're all feeling the same way it is
it's just heart-wrenching it's
heart-wrenching and to think that
all of these things are happening
because of the the
color of my skin you know when you
really break it down to it
yeah always denominator that's what it's
about
and i i don't i don't
understand why we have to consistently
deal with this and it's been over 400
years now i i think um
i think the demand for justice
and and the outcry for equality
um is much much louder now and i think
it's because of
all the generations before us and i it
just
it's culminated into this one
huge massive pact
um of of people who
are tired of it and we we don't want it
anymore we it has to go it has to go
we can't have this conversation again we
can't continue to have this conversation
you're right and what would you say what
is your definition of change
i think um it definitely starts um
uh politically uh economically and
socially
but i also think that um
this i don't know if this is gonna make
any sense
but i'm going to say it anyway because i
really in my heart and soul
i believe that it starts here
i think i have to
understand what the history
of slavery did to a people did to black
people
um without going into too much
uh of that
wretchedness um you have a
a whole race of people who um
who were indoctrinated in inferiority
and um we we couldn't pray we couldn't
read um the black family was torn apart
um black men were sold black babies were
sold
and so were black women and we were also
taught to
divide within our culture and so
if you have a people who don't
understand
who they are and and the love that they
once had for themselves was
was um erased
um then how
how can you have a people who love
themselves and and honor themselves
and know who they are and and and
are able to um take care of themselves
so that you can have other people
who respect us and you know which lends
itself to systemic racism
and that has has weighed on us
socially economically and politically
it's been it's been it's a construct
that's been written
um and created to keep black people
oppressed so when you go back and you
you look at people who don't have self
love
how do you do for yourself how do you do
for yourself
if you're constantly running up against
the construct and systems and laws
that won't allow you to get get ahead
economically
um and to do for yourselves to build for
yourself
so i think it starts there
it's a lot it's a lot and listening to
you it's a lot
it's a lot and you have been successful
for over what 30 years you just
celebrated an anniversary with onvoga
releasing your first album
and a lot of people are talking about
their own experiences and what they've
gone through
so you being in an industry i mean even
beyonce talks about starting her
own company so she would have a seat at
the table were you told to change your
ways
did it get better throughout the 30
years i mean does this all trigger
things that you went through in your own
industry
well you know we wrote a song
uh 30 years ago called free your mind
and um it it basically became
uh an anthem unfortunately for the
for this very thing what we're still
going through systematic racism
and um that song was written from four
girls
for black women uh uh
our personal perspective each girl wrote
her own verse about her own personal
perspective
in dealing with racism and and having
that experience
um and the message was for all of us
everyone to free our minds and and let's
sit down and talk
and and reconstruct things so that um
uh justice and equality works for
everyone
all of us um and here we are still
having the same conversation
um and so and just as a human being
um and knowing and having
um experienced racism myself
yes we've had success but it's really
hard
to measure quite honestly
when you continue to see people who look
just like you struggling yeah
i mean have we really had success you
know what i mean
yeah i think we've had a level of
success but i think we still have a long
way to go